All right, you did it. Final week, final lesson of
this incredible year studying apologetics, preparing your students to
be one step closer, to being entirely confident, to walk across the stage of
graduation, and to engage their culture with the truth of the gospel.
I can't express how excited I am to hear the
stories of our students and what they've been able to experience, and the stories of
students who started off with this skepticism and doubt and have been
brought along into committed followers of Christ, proclaiming the gospel far
beyond the walls of your youth group.
So this is exciting. I'm excited.
I hope you're excited. There's just a couple of quick things that I want to bring to
your attention and talk through as you kind of prepare.
I hope, first and foremost, I hope you are preparing to celebrate.
This has been probably one of some of the most difficult topics that some of your
students have ever dealt with in church studying, and that's awesome.
That makes me very, very excited.
So take the time to celebrate. But the second thing is take some time to do an
inventory.
Go back when we first started talking go back to where your students were have your
students go back to where they were and invite them to think through like what was I
thinking back go back to their notes and what were you thinking you know in
lesson 1.1 versus how you're thinking now when we in the concept of apologetics was
introduced and the questions that you had way back in the beginning have those
questions been answered now what further questions do you have?
Where do we go from here? How do we continue to move on?
For your seniors, ask them if they feel like they're ready.
And if they're not, maybe ask them what you can do to help them further be ready
for the next step, the next step in their lives, whether it be military, whether it
be college, whether it be gap year, whatever it is, what is next for them?
The next thing is success and failures.
For your storyteller, you want someone that can tell a great story
about sharing the truth. But keep this in mind.
You don't necessarily want to have somebody who successfully shared
the gospel every time. Students are going to need to see some examples
of sort of falling flat on their face because they're probably going to, and that's
okay, and maybe that's a good thing because you learn a lot more generally from
failure than you do from successes.
So have somebody that can express both sides, especially if you can find somebody
that failed, learned from their failure and moved on to some success.
Keep in mind and remind your students time and again
that it's not us who does the saving.
It is God's job. I have this analogy I've often given
students, and they're all going to be in different places.
And God's going to have all different kinds of roles, right?
Some water, some plant, but it's God who causes the growth.
And I often talk about the wide range of jobs from excavation to
tree shaking. I had this pastor friend of mine that I call him a tree shaker because
he's one of those guys that is just so eloquent and so good at
talking about the gospel that I think he can just say, bless you.
And people come to faith in Jesus.
He's just so good. God has just gifted him in amazing ways.
So I call him a tree shaker, right?
He just walks up to the tree that has been just, you know, ripened by a bunch of
work from a bunch of other people.
And he just gets up there and shakes that tree and the fruit just falls.
And that may be the giftings of some of your students, but that's not necessarily
gifting of all of your students.
I typically call myself an excavator.
I'm the guy that just messes people up and gets the land ready to be planted and
gets them all confused and thinking and gets people ready to hear truth and
understand what truth is. It could be all over the map.
So just remember to encourage your students that wherever they are on that spectrum,
to be faithful to the gifts and talents that God has given them.
That they're going to face some challenges.
They're going to face questions that they don't have answers to all the time.
They're going to have to seek them out.
They're going to have awesome success, and they're going to get the thrill of
leading someone to know Christ. And remember, we continue to pray for you.
We continue to work really hard here back at the home office to provide you with the
best possible resources for you to disciple your students.
Like I said, we would love to hear your stories we would love to hear how this study
has impacted you and impacted your students share them on facebook share them on
twitter and instagram give us an email give us a phone call whatever it takes let us
know how this study has impacted you and impacted your students in your ministry.